today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter today's guest has a new special
comedy special that is that is available
on the youtubes and we will put that
link right here below as well he's a
friend of mine he's a very unique man
very rare he's that rare earth element
something you find deep down in the dirt
he's the host of tinfoil hat podcast and
he is on the cutting edge of every
conspiracy theory
I mean I've fallen victim to the dark
arts and dabbled in them but I've never
gone spelunking in them like this sweet
chap here has my guest today is mr. Sam
Tripoli
[Music]
[Music]
always the pledge but I love you I'm so
happy you're doing well well we're doing
alright we can't decide what to paint we
don't know we're gonna do so those are
good problems have yeah what would you
just ask me a second ago she just buy
Bitcoin I feel I'm an everyday guy man I
make all the poor choices that every
other guy makes right so about a year
ago I bought probably $2,900 with a
Bitcoin yeah and I would be up all night
trying to figure out how to open up my
monaro wallet and and and I was up
switching and then I was buying I was
buying all kinds of like it went from
Bitcoin to like coin to like mert there
was like something else there was um
Lupita nyong I think I bought something
I was buying some deep [ __ ] bro I was
deep in the in the in the bit cord and
then it also then it all went out but
then some well now let's gone back up
it's worth like a grand now has it yeah
oh I didn't even I quit painting sister
because I had lost all of my money and
it was on to it it became embarrassing
it to discuss like who would know well
every guy could tell the look in every
guy's eyes that everybody had done the
same thing look at that dude
it's up to that so the reason I say buy
Bitcoin is because the economy is about
to drop out of nowhere and that's gonna
be the stuff that can't get touched mmm
so you buy a bunch of that and as
everybody's dying to get trying to get
their money out of the banks you don't
have to worry Bach cuz you got your
Bitcoin chillin like a you know a
villain mmm Bitcoin huh you know I have
a lot of it I just can't figure out
where it's at and how to get it dude
the best part of this is that some dude
was selling Chucky Cheese tokens to
people as bitcoins and people hurt by
big puppies for like who five grand dude
he's like yo you want a big coin dude I
got one right here
and people were buying them unreal we're
like a couple hundred bucks I guess and
who were the people just regular people
on the streets homeboy the streets well
dude I started getting emails from
buddies being like hey you want to
invest in this coin we're making yeah I
got to invest in just amazing that's the
dumbest thing I've ever it is stupid you
really think this is the future Samuel I
think that the bank's see so every bet
every country has what they call a
centralized bank and these centralized
banks can can do something called
fractional reserve banking which means
that they could they can loan out ten
dollars for every one dollar they have
in the bank which is basically funny
money it's like monopoly mine when
you're playing Monopoly with your with
your little brother and you're like hey
dude I'll buy that for and you just grab
like purple money and throw it at your
brother and he's like you like it well
it's not real money right it's fictional
money it's just like hedging it's like
just credit yeah it's it's made-up book
made-up made-up money dude and that's
really what these really smart lizards
did they made this [ __ ] make up money
and they bribed everybody with it but
eventually you're going to eventually
what happens is they everybody invests
in all this money right and then the
people at the real top who have all the
actual wealth which they say out of all
the wealth and world only 20% of its
real and they have this 20% eventually
they pull their notes in and in all
collapse and they're the only ones with
money but with this Bitcoin they can't
do that oh wow so this is finally people
striking back against so I always yeah
Jewelry servers against the people with
the gold bow you know how we got the
Federal Reserve and you could tell me to
shut up anytime well you know I would
never do that the Federal Reserve came
Woodrow Wilson on Christmas Eve when
everybody left Washington DC he gave us
two bills that he signed and nobody
didn't nobody voted on the Federal
Reserve any income tax we used to only
pay taxes personal taxes when we were in
money more oh really and when we weren't
war there was no personal tax he brought
both
at the exact same time like if I see
Messiah anybody in history I'd fight
Woodrow Wilson wolf really yeah I
[ __ ] knuckle up with that dude
hard but do you think so why did he do
it because what did you think he had a
back end from the government yeah he had
bankers this thing is called the monster
from Jekyll Island all these bankers man
on Jekyll Island they brought in Federal
Reserve now you wanna hear something
really crazy hmm do you want brought you
here yeah okay oh that's one of the
reasons why I'm glad you're here today
that's what I'm man and then I'll stop
after this the Abraham Lincoln half the
real reason the Civil War happened was
in slavery that was part of it but the
real thing was is that basically the
United States no longer wanted a
centralized Bank and it got to the point
where Abraham Lincoln issued something
called greenbacks and these were his
dollar bills and if you can actually
find a greenback it's worth a lot a lot
of money so what happened was that the
the international bankers went to the
south coalition you could keep slaves we
have to have centralized bank and they
agreed to that what was about to happen
was that Britain and Spain were gonna
come in on the side of the south well
Alexander the second from Russia heard
about this and they just kicked out all
the all the international bankers out of
Russia
he sent naval ships Russian naval ships
to the US shores and said if you get
involved in this Britain and Spain we're
gonna get involved on the side of the
north and they pulled out and then it
was just mano a mano and that's how it
didn't happen nobody ever knows that
dude is that alexander ii came in on the
side of abraham lip rial they call him
running around that's crazy man it's
just all money goes back to the dollars
man everything goes back they didn't
want yeah I mean here's a thing man
would you have a slave if they had him
now to everybody if it was would I have
a slave I probably couldn't afford it
but say you could afford it I mean
probably not I mean I'm just not really
into that I'd be I can tell my dog what
it does you have an iPhone now I do have
an iPhone that is okay that's a point no
I'm saying that was like people were
doing there
job and not doing it real well they were
lost yeah people were confused you know
people were out there and suddenly
somebody came by with something that was
just like hey dude they'll do the work
just better yeah I got you bringing up
valid points now here's one thing that I
think a lot of times people don't think
about thinking about slavery was you
think they just think oh all white
people had slavery dude only rich people
dude basically the equivalent of Bill
Gates and Zuckerberg owned slaves at
that time
yeah and that's always the problem it's
always that 1% that basically causes all
the problems you know it's not it's
there's levels to this [ __ ] yeah and
everybody gets in fights with each other
over over just race and sex and gender
and and sexuality when in reality it's
it's levels of Finance it's it's rich
versus poor but they'll never get us all
to come together on that [ __ ] broke-ass
[ __ ] man I'm from broke-ass I'm
upstate New York Mike alia had the
number highest rate of incest and
welfare recipients in all of New York
State where he's God baby yeah thanks
God like it was [ __ ] dawg we were shady
oh that's neck tattoo conscious jessimae
Peluso country yeah that is three issues
one three one five I'm six oh seven
she's amazing she is amazing so we're
shady like my mom used to teach schools
and she would always tell me about kids
come to school
dirty dirty clothes dirty underwear no
money for food drug-addicted parents
might where am I talking about you know
it's like dude we're more like them
their lice
oh yeah dude getting the measles back
when it didn't mean nothing dude I
remember telling some kids in Beverly
Hills about lice they thought it was a
rap group I thought it was like like
[ __ ] lice yeah people going through
your hair and bugs in your head in your
[ __ ] brain yeah dude I'm talking
about you who so many lies you hear that
they're [ __ ] parting your hair at
lunch the offer riding like highways in
your head [ __ ] I'm talking about think
you're talking to somebody and a couple
of lice and just [ __ ] mosey on down
your cheek really we're explorers they
were over there oh that's frickin Lou
that's license and Clark bro I'm talking
about the original chemtrails bro
and a couple of stray license trees just
I don't know I'm trying to find better
lands do whenever you walked in here so
you know we're talking and on Nick and
Jionni are in here too and we're talking
that you um next door there's a
pornography management company what is
it no agency agency dude let me just
tell you something what happened to porn
yeah well first let me tell you this I
was I was probably in the past nine
months I've bet I've watched porn twice
for the first time in my life yeah I'm
getting off on that [ __ ] I'm getting I'm
getting off it okay good yeah you have
to remove the comment yes I'm getting
off it otherwise you're just coming at
the house really buta I do joke about my
life is change bro it is change course
dude but my desire is slowly it's crazy
I never thought it would be this way but
it's slowly coming back to be a little
bit more normal yeah it really is and I
never thought it could happen I just
realized it a week ago I was like man I
just have a little more realistic
interest in the opposite sex
not just this like kind of compulsive
interest that ends up with me just
jerking off at home yeah well dude I
mean it gets weird they're still making
porn I can't believe that I mean I'm
beating off to porn from 2008 still most
chicks I beat off to or dead you know
I'm sorry praise God long dude and
should they have a section in there that
is for just like these or disease haha
dude the in memoriam at the AVN's is
literally half the show it's like half
the people they lost that year it just
keeps going dude and why is it killing
is it excessive sex that's killing
people
yeah they're odine on dick uh no dude
it's just like they're like comics man
listen dude if you realize how similar
oh yeah comics and porn stars are we
have the exact same business model dude
okay they do a porno we do a special
they do camps we do podcasting Wow we
tore off our podcast they tore off their
Cammie and their pornos when we when
we're the top act of the club we're
headliners when they're the top act at a
strip bar there
headliners they have fans only we have
patreon I mean it's the exact same model
drug problems daddy issues all the exact
same thing yeah and we just die left and
right dude yeah man it's so you know
what that surgery I've thought about
that before man it's like and we get up
and show we both are showing ourselves
in some way for them it's physical you
got a lot of times or it's sexual for us
it's uh it's more emotional yeah prior
self to sleep both of us right yeah man
I used to share I used to share a an
apartment with a stripper and they're
very it's very similar I mean it's you
know and our lives were very very
similar man we would both leave at night
and come back late and you know it was
both like there was the highs of the
work but those were gone and then the
drugs and here we were yeah and then
there was opportunity I you're just more
around opportunities for more drugs and
alcohol you got to feel yourself he's a
young man's game dog oh it is I used to
love that coco champion like I'll have
lost skills but one of them is [ __ ]
on coke I just had this [ __ ] had this
this dick that just could just crush on
coke and that was my skill and I get why
like pro athletes die to deaths they
lose their like their athletic skill and
then they die when they die same thing
with me it's like I can't do coke
[ __ ] anymore I'm too old so I that
death and now eventually the Reaper will
come for me but I get it dude when you
have these skills as youth but I could
[ __ ] on coke that's amazing man and how
did you even learn that because yeah I
would get on cocaine and I remember like
I would hire and once I'm hiding from
some girl who was trying to [ __ ] me yeah
cuz you got that nub going I was just so
scared no I thought I don't know in my
head like I thought she was trying to
steal something like my biggest thing
was oh and feel your soul in your hole
[Laughter]
remember I would take all my stuff
before so a girl would come over and
hide it all over in my apartment like I
mean everything dude anything that any
value I would hide cover things up with
blankets like it literally looked like I
was like a paint
like in my own place like I was like
Sherwin Williams jr. who are you right
over your house you gotta hide
everything just I thought I thought good
women you know but and then I was just
you know because I would be so nervous
paranoid in my head oh they're gonna
steal [ __ ] they're gonna steal this
they're gonna steal that they gonna feel
like my family photos they're gonna
steal my keys so weird they stoled your
family and they try to hawk that from
[ __ ] coke i got the steel ball with
grandma can I give all I don't think it
was like that I just they were gonna
steal my mementos they were gonna steal
like anything that had any value I would
hide it so then I'm at my apartment and
right when they get there I'm like oh
this [ __ ] is trying to steal right even
if they just just like rang the doorbell
I'm like oh what's that I'm [ __ ] alarm
for somebody that's trying to steal you
know it's always start tripping dude and
it was just yeah we're the last chicks
huh
we're you meeting now be on the internet
on vague sites on the internet or social
media or just had bumped into them you
know whose back page for a little bit
yeah I got in a back page man and it's
uh you know it's a unique blend of
society yeah I got a rep dude that guy
got arrested and straight-up play guilty
to who mark back page yeah dude is so
funny I felt like I just found like
black strippers on Instagram like my
whole like Instagram feed is just like
Oakland Raiders and black strippers
that's all it is my I'm like that
Starbucks near the airport just like
black blue JA right oh it's like the
Democratic Party yeah for sure dude and
dude they always hit me up and they're
always soliciting sex and I'm like no
but one time I did a clown with a
somewhat black hand smiley and like
thumbs up she accused me being racist no
way dude let who's our guest for today
well that could be the porn agency next
door can you guys hear that banging huh
someone's someone's auditioning it could
be so you were saying earlier when you
came in saying that something has killed
the porn industry what were you talking
about
well I just think the men in the porn
industry have uh I've killed it they
have uh why is porn free
that's the question why is porn free I
think it's all CIA psyops dog really to
get you to look at get into weirder and
weirder [ __ ] well let me think about it
on a second so you asked why porn is
free let me think
so porn is free I've never really been
presented that porn was any other way I
think you know I mean when I was young
porn was more secretive yeah you go to
like go to Blockbuster you go through
those wooden doors everyone would know
somebody just walked into the adult
thing and you grab a porno and the porno
like cover was like Almanack thick right
and you'd have to carry this giant video
up to the case and cushion it would hit
and everyone knew you were getting like
dirty deafeat on seven right yeah and
all the women are on the front yeah they
were all Debbie Does Dallas and on a hat
you know hoots yeah and it looked like
professional yeah yeah dude a special
dude if you remember growing up man
like the the [ __ ] freaky chick in
your school there was like one oh yeah
and she was a freak and she everybody
loved her or everybody hated her but
that was she was special
oh it's like everybody's like that yeah
there's no lovin it's like there's
nobody special i buy they're all freaks
well I mean I think we had this girl
yeah dude they had this girl named I
think what was that girl's name panty
maybe when he is Winnie and named Winnie
is a name but Ian my penny I don't think
it was Jenny I remember that but she
could stand on one leg right get the
other leg get a q-tip and clean her ear
with it pull it up to her ear like this
one yes yeah pulled her stand-up just
like you're just like a flamingo with a
damn you know with a sinus infection I
mean she could just lift one of her legs
up to her ear with a q-tip between her
toes and clean out her ear how do you
even know you had that skill I mean I
think maybe your dad's a Dana you know
yeah it's a dentist I don't I have no
idea or something you ever you know you
work at a ear nose and throat clinic
outpatient work I have no idea but do
didn't she was yeah I mean dude I mean
people would salute to her in the
morning she was the damn she was our
Vietnam ask you
she was yeah she'd her own parading [ __ ]
oh yeah respect from people loved her I
mean they called her yes she was just
like a flamingo she could just I mean
she could clean her ear and just a
heartbeat god I wish I had that skill
but now yeah I guess I'm my left foot
[ __ ] yeah but with the holiday Louis
yeah he was so good in that he was good
and he was good in everything what isn't
he good at I don't know God go live in a
[ __ ] log cabin working on his [ __ ]
good mr. t died today can't believe that
[ __ ] off can't believe that what you
didn't know that mr. T died what I'm
joking about I know it's RS gonna said
it I shoulda said it I'm sorry dude you
can't joke about that no I know you joke
about anybody else in the a team dying
that's funny yeah but mr. t that's rough
you know I remember we were gonna field
trips when we were young we were on like
camping trips for a couple days and
right before we'd all get in the car but
like yeah I tell everybody that somebody
really that everybody loved it died just
so for the for the next 48 hours I was
in my own world where Jay Leno had died
or you know somebody that abreu people
really enjoy it do did you know that
like Roseanne Barr didn't know about
9/11 to like two weeks after like she
was in the log cabin chillin and she
didn't know till two weeks later when
she got home but 9/11 happened that's
awesome you know what I was thinking the
other day man I was in Australia and I
was that always awesome man
how cool is it that you can go to a
foreign country and just be loved yeah
yeah crazy man I mean it almost feels
like a like a not even real thing you
know I hate to say that I mean I know
they're real people in Australia and I
saw them all the chicks are Tom pregnant
you know it's that oh yeah everyone
nobody pulls out in Australia Oh nobody
it's like it's a felony over there oh
definitely dude you can come in anything
over there I mean everything over there
looks like it's ready like it oh [ __ ] I
mean they got aardvarks running around
you know oh yeah with lipstick they got
an T there's a lipstick on her snout
people meet each other dude yeah I
watched a dude hump a tree yesterday oh
yeah where was that at one of the parks
oh it was over there on Santa
Monica do just wood on wood hard hard
hard just going for mm dude loved
[ __ ] loves nature yeah that's hard
man I wouldn't get out like that I never
been you got to be I've had that at that
point you're probably on some drugs or
something you know or just wants to
really save the environment
yeah you guys if you haven't checked out
you can check out to us tinfoil hat
how's it going Sam because it's I need
to annoy I keep tune with what's going
on through Tim for hat why I've been
watching you know you've been talking
about the moon and stuff yeah
what's your thoughts on that my biggest
thing it's really getting me right now
is I start to think sometimes like I was
just thinking about the news the other
day right and like I don't even like the
news is at a point now where I don't
even not only do not trust it I start to
find it like invasive now and I know you
like it
they're all starting to make me like I
used to get angry sometimes if I didn't
agree with the news or I didn't agree
with the network or something like that
or but now it's more like man I don't
think this is such [ __ ] or whatever
I don't have a I don't know if it's true
or not that I can't believe that it's
allowed to permeate it's such a that
it's allowed to just constantly have a
frequency oh yeah man that mean it's
just a propaganda it's meant to get us
all to believe in some weird stuff so
NASA is very interesting you know what
the the Hebrew word for deceive is
mm-hmm not sure which is n s H a ok ok
so I'm gonna tell you I I did this joke
it's a it's a stupid joke but a Nazi our
Satanist and a Scientologist walk into a
bar what do they do
a Nazi Satanist Scientologist
um what time is it at the bar
it is about 6:30 p.m.
yeah probably sit down order a drink
they create NASA that's who invented
NASA uh so you had a question you had
vom Braun who was a Nazi you had Jack
Parsons who is a known Satanist and you
had l ron Hubbard and they together
formed NASA so when von Braun dies did
I'll know if Eddie Bravo I told you this
but if you look on his tombstone it is
says Psalms 19:1
do you want to look that up real quick
okay so Psalms 19:1
what is that about well that is a
passage in the Bible that talks about
the filament okay this Parliament the
firmament well that's the stuff yeah
that people think is around us enough no
that is a dome
I don't why is the guy who invented NASA
talking about a dome it's some
interesting [ __ ] dude the filament is a
dome right there heavens
yeah baba boom yeah there's right there
it's below it but it's so interesting
dude you know I uh do you believe in a
God do you believe in a higher power I
believe that we are in assimilation and
that within that simulation we were
aliens came called Anunnaki
they splice their genes with this group
called the are they called the something
tablets where they called the [ __ ]
this group the Sumerians the Sumerians
okay the Sumerians were meant to be a
worker force right which is us then they
created this group above it uh and they
were to control us so it's like why were
there pharaohs why is their royal family
and now that came out that the royal
family that Queen Elizabeth is related
to Mohammed so this whole elite crowd is
all related to each other why is that
dude because
they were created to control and then it
all starts to make sense so I believe
was the dark arts dark arts talk and how
do you feel like so say if we are all
under this under some sort of a that
there's a Allegiant out there that is
pulling the strings right yes how do you
get up the string far enough to swing at
the hand you know - you don't you don't
you know I mean like it would it well
what's gonna what's gonna happen is the
entire group of us or have to all come
together hmm can we do it we can all you
have to do is just unplug from the news
and all that telev it all that should
unplug stop buying into black versus
white straight versus gay men versus
women all that stuff so realizing that
your brother man is I'm and that it's
rich versus poor once you do that you
start realizing we're all the same boat
together right and that's how it's gonna
rise up but they can't they have to
listen to us I don't care if you're
China or anything if the masses pulls
back push back or even withdraws the
whole thing crashes so they have to play
with us Psychopaths which are these
lizard people whether they're real
lizards or they just have more reptilian
brain in them they are psychopaths and
they can't create so like when you hear
about a guy who steals jokes right
they're all psychopaths they can't
create yet so they at the jack jokes to
the get [ __ ] going they can't create and
that's why Psychopaths and this group of
this elite level supposedly feeds off
our pain and suffering so that's why
we're always like you ever take time off
from watching the news and then go back
a month later and you watch you're like
oh it hurts
it's like you ever take time off from
eat McDonald's and then like two months
later you go eat a mcdonald's and your
buy just is like you know what are you
doing yeah like that's the body's like
are we in a car accident you but it's
but it's good yeah so it's the same
thing damn dude well but now there's but
say if you live in that Montauk
conspiracy's engine I find it
interesting I do I mean yeah I don't
know I can talk to anything mullets I
had a mullet in high school I used to
break dance with a mullet on do you know
how hard that is to do a [ __ ] backs
you in with a [ __ ] mullet
is there any other way first of all to
do one yeah second of all this is just a
long men's haircut yeah this isn't
necessarily a mullet in a lot of
countries this is just considered just
kind of like an adult man's haircut
where I come from that is a mullet is it
and I respect to [ __ ] out that
yeah I'm fine pictures of me rocking
that [ __ ] really can we get that up do
you mind yeah I know I have to post them
I'll send to you just like the
government man yeah oh [ __ ] dude afraid
do you think um do you think we're
headed towards state government that's
something that I think about a lot
because I think that it could benefit us
like you know recently you have like the
issue with um you know you have people
talking about the abortion and stuff
like that right to choose and right and
and I certainly get like if a woman
saying this is my body
why I'd it's my farmland if I'm gonna
grow something in it that's up to me
right whatever song women's vaginas has
grown [ __ ] let me see let me lick that
gurll yeah but I'm saying this is that
I'm not shocked that a state that has a
lot of Christian beliefs or a lot of
Christian values in its history I'm not
shocked that if Georgia that that's the
choice that they made well isn't that is
let me just say something but that's a
little it doesn't shock me that's what
I'm saying like I'm not saying it's
right or wrong I'm just saying that is
the surprise right that's that that's
their choice
well here's let me say something about
Alabama uh I get I'm from upstate New
York white trash to the bone we got
nothing but cows and meth labs white
trash to the bone
okay 607 white trash July right so I'm
not here to say the old stupid redneck
I'm from that okay but when you look at
Alabama is bottom five in education and
their economy is bottom five the last
people I want telling me who should be
allowed to live and who should be
allowed to die are the people who are
failing in life okay right you are not
succeeding you are bottom drought you
are the bottom
the barrel and it's no disrespect I've
been Alabama I like the people are nice
you are failing in these very important
categories you should not be allowed to
tell the rest of us whether we should be
able to bring people into life or not
now a very dark arts thing about about
abortion and who shouldn't should it is
that when they allowed the legalization
of abortion the crime rate dropped okay
and what we're seeing right now today is
that the crime rate is down and nobody's
joining the military and that is not
good for the lizard people because the
military-industrial complex and the
prison industrial complex
they want their prisons full and they
want soldiers for their wars so what
better way to have it then have a bunch
of people born into a world where maybe
the parents don't want them put into
foster care and if you're in foster care
and you survived it I'm not being
disrespectful to you but it's like early
military what a lot of fuss girls
basically early military yeah make is a
product of foster care right here right
I mean dude and I'm not here to be
disrespect me buddy but it I think they
should have an NFL team dude the foster
care team the pre safety has an axe you
know I think it's very respectable but
but here's what I'm saying is you but
also a lot of people leave these these
cities in these states and go to other
places to do business so it's like it's
like a lot of these places they don't
have the same opportunity to you know a
lot of states they don't have the same
opportunities that other states have you
know to be like numbers you know to be
number one in these different categories
and this and that like you know it's
like a lot of them don't have the same
opportunities well I understand that but
then they shouldn't be allowed to
dictate the national discussion on this
subject
it's just like I get people leaving well
yeah maybe there's a reason and I have
no problems with Alabama other than then
trying to dictate to us something that
we've already agreed upon right right I
just feel so something we are practicing
like a lot of people are getting
abortions you can get an abortion almost
a CVS already for soon on amaz
on the other day Michigan hotel offers
pretty accommodations I mean dude you
it's hard to make a dollar you gotta do
whatever you can man like one night free
breakfast a free abortion oh yeah I got
that shun Travelocity the other day do
will serve these eggs and will unser
those all types of scrambled eggs oh I
can't I mean it's I mean nobody wants it
to be used as a form of birth control if
you get to a certain place obviously
that's a child but at some point early
on it's like it if they don't if they
don't want bring it on you know it is
what it is dude yeah but but it's not so
that's why I'm wondering if it's state
governments and you can have a state
that's like okay our government is a lot
more Christian based or Islamic based
whatever whatever they want their you
know their beliefs to be and then people
can choose okay I want to live in this
area where this is what that is I just
feel like the national conversation
doesn't help because it's we're not
living in the same places man it's two
different places I can go to some places
in like in Alabama in some places in
different areas yeah they don't care
about big business they don't care they
care about their family they care about
spending time together I respect that
and that to them is a valuable life I
get that now respect right and I'm not
saying you don't I'm just trying to like
sometimes there's not a there's not like
a voice that has like an understanding
of what's going on there
so some do you think state governments
would help I we have state governments
if you see what's going on with weed
right now a weed is being legalized on a
state level and the problem with that
it's not being legalized on a federal
level and a reason that's dangerous
because now they're using that as a way
to take away your guns so if you get a
weed license in let's say Colorado
federally you're not allowed to own a
gun and that's the backdoor thing and
that's why we should legalize it on a
federal level so they can't do that and
that you know I'm watching these
liberals getting really like like cool
with censorship and taking away their
guns and I would ask them to take a look
at what's going on right now in France
where we have the one
has the guns and the other group doesn't
the state has the guns and the
protesters at the the yellow vest oh and
guess who's shooting who okay if you
take a look at the United States there's
two other country I think of very
similar United States in terms of
population the United States China
Russia if you look above when Russia and
China took away their guns there was
mass slaughter twenty million people
each country
we're killed after they took away guns
and then if you look at these countries
right now and how these liberals love
guns being take away take a look at ah
the China Russia very anti-gay very
anti-gay and very anti feminine I mean
women I mean like a you high five over
there you got a high five fast bro yeah
don't let your palms Miller right dude
they try to do a mr. gay Chinese in
Beijing I think it was I went there to
do stand-up at this hard rock which
Steve Byrne and a month before they're
about to have mr. gay Chinese and the
government shut that [ __ ] down
yeah and then you think about if ten
percent of your population is gay that's
a hundred million gay Jin's dog yeah
that's an army that angry yeah angry
gauge in stock so the point is that
there's there's a history to watch yeah
yeah but taking away guns and it's not a
good history at all so last year in 2018
two hundred and about seventy-five
people died in mass shootings I was
three hundred and seventy five which is
each one of those is a huge tragedy
converse to that is that nine hundred
ninety two people were shot killed by
cops
so that's who everybody wants to give
the guns to right you only want the cops
have that now if you compare that every
year on average a thousand people died
from autoerotic fixation what's that
jerking off in the clock yeah with a
belt around your neck that's crazy so we
have more people dying from belts around
the neck turkey off we have a bigger
problem with people jerk you off the
weird [ __ ] no more bouts
no more belt and why they don't know the
what do you does something happen they
don't remember where the belt where
their belt goes no I think they fall
they gets uh and my point ease get a
spotter
have somebody back a friend when you're
strapped you know it's it's a amount of
air that's in your so it's like right
before you're about to pass out but some
people don't like tell us your
experience with it I have never done it
but I'm not saying that I would never do
it really now what do you you're talking
about autoerotic yeah Association yeah
it's uh yeah David Carradine and what
happens you said Gianni that's like a
belt it's like like you take the air out
while you're jerking off um people go
too far and then they they can't breathe
and then they die and then it's cool
yeah hmm right where they jerk and off
at David Copperfield's house no dude
just jerk off it takes a minute
some people are bored dude they just
like it weird they go so deep down that
hall they're jerking off the weird ass
[ __ ] now that is something that
pornography starts to it now pornography
will rot your brain it's one of the
things that I believe has really really
really ruined men you know I think it's
ruined a lot of men in my generation it
has just salted us to the point where
you don't even look at a what you know
it's just like I don't know I say man
but me I notice it really just burnt me
out man yeah well I mean I hear a golf
I'd make a big plan for the night in
jerk off and do nothing have a couple of
[ __ ] you know vanilla cream sandwich
cookies or some lemon cookies if I was
you know if it was like a special time
and that's all I did yeah you know Andy
still jerks off Johnny very young Johnny
how old you 23 just oh my god I'll drink
blood out of the dudes arm right now
wait wait do you think it's bad for when
you're at this age or when you get older
no because you're just starting new and
but dude eventually what you drug it off
to now won't get you off so you go a
little deeper and that's what all that
[ __ ] is like oh if you like this I'm
pouring up you'll love this and next
thing you know you're like wow that
chicks got a fat dick you know kids
already putting belts around his neck in
your gym Noren yeah you get weird dog
yeah man it gets weird or wet and women
are getting weird or - I think than they
used to be they're getting more sexual
it seems like they're all into that nope
everybody's worried about like all these
Christians worried about gay sex
what about like BDSM them all these
chicks are into like this weird like
lock them up and they can't do anything
you light them up like you got you got a
sad chick signed contracts now before
you have sex it's like you're cool with
all this [ __ ] yeah right oh you'll come
out in the morning find some chick oh
yeah you got a call pot you know the
Papa log dude just to get you know to
get the date out of your locks I lost
the key this chicks in a weird thing
with a [ __ ] horse dildo in your ass
yeah I got a check over here with a
couple goldfish in her mouth and brother
can you head on over in a tease no one
choked anyone during sex everyone choked
oh now dude they had a thing some guy
like try to yeah like put a rope around
his truck and then try to choke a woman
with he's think if he didn't like yeah
just went about 4 miles an hour she
would just choke it's just stunt [ __ ]
that's what it is
just stop [ __ ] yeah Tokio dick yeah
too fast to carry too fast too curious
Gold
dude that's gold yeah we have time a
normal dog only took us 2 years have a
[ __ ] all of us tell a good joke
unbelievable that's what you do Sam you
bring people together like that I know I
guess I try to think of what some of our
fears are trying to get out of like you
know there's a lot of traps out there
though that's one thing I start to think
about like there's a lot of traps where
it's like ok we'd be very obvious for me
right now to think this to think that
just this is what's going on like you
know like the news sometimes I don't
agree with some of the news and I'm like
but it almost seems too easy for me like
if I'm like oh the news is just tricking
like dumb people yeah but then if I'm
just thinking that is there another
trick going on that I know there's a
trick beyond the trick yeah like I just
start to want like it makes me really
kind of question you know I feel a
little bit scared I feel a little bit I
was in a meeting today and they're like
yeah we want you know we only want to
try and do shows that are with
marginalized communities and you know we
really
you know we want that marginalized voice
that voice that hasn't been heard you
know that that is our when I said no
right and I said oh good I said because
I want to just tell you know my stories
just you know just a poor white kid and
I don't see that story anywhere right
now yeah you know I'm not saying that
other other ethnicities or cultures I
know it's hard I know
I can't imagine sometimes the journey
that some people have been through but
they were just make it all even like
what are we still but but just but to
sit here and like forced you know an air
you know a story about a you know a guy
from Tibet who's homosexual and he sold
all his organs and now he's you know
that's what happened and it's like what
do we do like counterculture right that
nobody watched it like they would have
these days and life ones like I'm a gay
porn star it's like how many people want
to like who's watching that nothing if
you're gay porn sir
I'm the ionizer I've interviewed gay
porn you have a black people do it like
you do you do but ha what I feel like
television got away from ratings but
then again I start thinking ratings
aren't real
there's no ratings I'm not gonna say the
show but there was a famous show they'll
quote quote famous show it was on
forever and I would go up on stage ago
how many people what I go to just packed
up how many people watch that show
nobody would ever go to the torkelson
you guys ever see the torkelson no dude
god it was good it was good just the ten
of us remember that yeah I remember that
bro how did that guy ever end up with
all this chicks dude ratings aren't real
dude I'm not gonna tell you the name of
the show because I will it's called the
Big Bang I mean I go like how many
people watching nobody and then you
learn remember you're growing up and
people like how do they get TV ratings
and they were like these Nielsen and
these mystery people had and nobody knew
anybody with Nielsen box but they would
tell you ratings do you not radio to
size the ratings dude they have somebody
walk around they say with this thing
that just listens around well and when
they hear radio it registers and that's
how they know it's all [ __ ] the
other dude the award the awards shows oh
that's a [ __ ] though this accounting
firm is the only firm that knows the
results who owns an accounting firm same
people that owned all the networks
it's all [ __ ] and then you look at
television okay so you have these five
groups that own everything they own
every television channel and they own
everybody advertising so it's just a
[ __ ] money shell game it's all
[ __ ] it's the reason they call it
programming dude cuz their price that
called scheduling
it's called programming dude it's all
[ __ ] it's meant to get us all the
fight with each other so if you stop
watching it you realize it's a beautiful
world out there yeah you stop everyone's
like it's oh I'm so sick and tired of
the you want to hear something crazy
dude
go read yeah [ __ ] Unabomber x'
manifesto bro how long you want to read
so it's a little long but you want to
read some [ __ ] dude read just get on
audiobooks and just have somebody read
that [ __ ] to you and you read dude he
breaks down everything going on right
now do technology how liberalism will be
hijacked by rich [ __ ] kids right who
[ __ ] will be like liberal liberal and
how they don't really like they don't
they don't it's not when they're they're
crying about minorities or the
disenfranchised it's not that they
respect they actually feel [ __ ] pity
on them like they're lesser than yes I
notice that a lot of times like people
are like all these people it's so sad
look at them yeah it's like what do you
mean look at them like we are them
you're all them like so implicit does a
story about how like these liberals want
to get rid of voter ID law so Infowars
whatever you think about it I don't
watch it but this was a really
interesting video they go to Berkeley
they interview all these white college
kids and they're like so why you against
voter ID laws it's like well you know
the black community they're really poor
and they don't have IDs and it's really
hard for them to get on the internet and
it's really hot and then so they go to
Brooklyn and they interview all these
lack people like hey do you have an IDs
like yeah do you have the Internet I
have the phone so in reality they look
down on these [ __ ] people yeah and
that's what you see happening so I'm not
gonna get into name but there so this
one famous um director said he wouldn't
have white leads in this movie and he's
allowed to write it's his [ __ ] movies
right he could have whatever the [ __ ] he
wants
I think it's an unnecessary statement
well this
one big-name comedian retweets it and
goes oh where will white guys ever get
roles again oh yeah everywhere and this
is an actor who is booking all the time
right it's so it's like really
condescending to say that right and then
you look at him you're like who is this
mother for oh he's some rich kid from
San Francisco who went to private
schools and there's a trust fund kid
yeah
it's the kid I think it was get out of
that movie and then this guy Jordan
Peele I'm making movies after us I don't
see myself casting a white dude as the
lead even though his the number one
leading his life his wife is white yeah
I love him he could do whatever he wants
it's his project but that's an
unnecessary statement but when you you
have well that that statement to me is
divisive a little bit like but you know
I I don't know I feel like sometimes
yeah like the if you feel slighted or
you feel like there's not opportunity
for you you can't you have to still like
a vengefulness doesn't help you know
like sometimes I wish there were more
videos and stuff like like I never seen
a video where like a group of black
people go help out a white family you
know make the video right that's what I
thought of the other day I think I've
never seen it I was like I should make
something like that may just to inspire
like not that that needs to happen but
it just I think like it's always just
like this thing like there's just one
way about it or zone it's like we are
more like than we are
so much so and it's just these old ideas
man that primal is fight with you I do
Joey initial you guys should check out
my special it's on YouTube right and I
put it out I made all my money back
yes check out it's called Sam Tripoli
live from the Viper Room there's a
Armageddon and Zero Fox but I talk about
the colors and why it's not about Black
Studies green privilege it's about green
and what's green what's money lizard
aliens lizard oh yeah that's right I've
watched some of it I've watched a little
bit of it and if you go like look at
this dude I mean like dude we are more
like that we are going when when a cop
shoots an unarmed black man that's
shooting all of us are unarmed
I agree I mean dude when the [ __ ]
powers have become that [ __ ] crush
the resistance they send cops and
they're cracking white skulls and black
skulls and straight skulls and and gay
skulls and all that [ __ ] oh I'm Way more
scared of a black cop in a white cop I
think I'm more afraid of dude of all the
cop I got Sir Jack bro except for that
one with the moustache is always not
jacked carl winslow tiny cops are in LA
there's like lupa cops oh I saw a guy
yeah his nightstick was way in him man
dude yeah you had to carry it on a
shoulder like this we got some questions
that came in what about you guys you
have any questions for Sam Nick or
Gianni it's rare that we get in these
same as a guy that goes deep into the
dark artists you're kind of like the
Neal
you're like the Neal dark grass Tyson
you know you're like going deep into the
darkness man you're in there you're
mining you're a miner you're like all 57
of those gallopping miners or whatever
they got trapped under the thing yeah
but you're one man down there now I'm
one man doing not dude I just I just
might podcast tinfoil hat is history
list yeah we just study history and when
you see it all lines up and then you
realize there's not different
conspiracies it's all part of the same
Spears oh there's something I definitely
feel like but do you feel like the
resistance is growing oh yeah dude every
day you wouldn't believe how many people
listen to me I would believe it in
heartbeat I was at home I was at home in
my town and I was at a I was at a cafe
and it was uh called Mandy's Cafe I was
having breakfast over there with my
stepdad and this lady sits down and she
goes you know Eddie Bravo
you know Sam Tripoli I love those guys
don't tell anybody here I'm flattered
that's what she said that she wrote me
some [ __ ] grits I'm dying
Tiger Woods he's bangin Waffle House ass
right like a champion yes I'm saying
you're starting with the people and this
was a woman I never would have expected
that cool lady you know I just never
would have expected that and then there
was BAM and I'm like wow people are
starting to think outside of of the bun
in an info hat man it's for the people
it's the wu-tang dog like a new wu-tang
yeah it's right well it's just there's a
lot of stuff that it definitely feels
like [ __ ] is shady bro and but it also
starts to feel like the rich the the
elite are starting to get their kids are
getting weak because they're not putting
in the work that their parents did for
sure do for sure you start to see that
mm-hmm I mean I feel like every kid that
I've grown like I've seen out here that
has successful parents and they're
working in the industry man they're the
[ __ ] laziest ones of them all they're
gonna lose a swordfight in a heartbeat
well the big thing is that they just
they become these super liberals and
they push all this like fight you know
these guys are bad but it's like all
their parents and grandparents made
money in this stuff that they're railing
against and you never hear that [ __ ]
they never tell you that that like who
their parents are and what their parents
did and they present themselves thank
you sweetie
Jaden Smith dude I mean I there's comics
I'll tell you about their parents like
shady as [ __ ] and they're going around
acting like they're all like liberal
blah blah and it's like damn dude shady
as [ __ ] pushing getting people fighting
with each other all the time because
they push the agenda dude and it's like
the liberal movement got hijacked you
know how many [ __ ] liberals are
pro-war like how are you liberal and pro
war yeah I don't want anybody to die
yeah I heard a dime for bankers dawg
yeah man then you learn about how like
the United States history the United
States power structure was pretty much
built on opium that all the like Ivy
League schools were founded by opium
families who who made billions in opium
selling opium in China and that's why in
China if you're caught dealing drugs
it's the death penalty because the whole
country got hooked on British opium and
those families came here and built the
basic theme our structure of this
country all the [ __ ] Ivy League
schools were founded by a different
opium family and like the skull and
crossbones created by an opium family
called the Russell's
and when you graduate you got 250,000
the equivalent $250,000 to give you a
heads up on anybody else
we're deep
but it's very plain when you learn about
you learn dude right use not don't run
the banks Muslim so hate your freedoms
gays aren't corrupting the youth white
people aren't racist women aren't
[ __ ] [ __ ] Hispanics aren't here to
take your jobs it's all lizard people
dog and when you realize that you love
everybody yeah everybody just I dude
you've toured the world
I've been Afghanistan I've been in
Muslim countries those people are the
nicest people ever lambs we call them
yeah but yeah and I came up with that
myself pretty good I love them and thank
you very much loving yeah dude I love a
Muslim brother Muslim I'll get up under
the sheets with them dude I'm [ __ ] oh
you're a lot of Muslims like walking
beds do my favorite thing to do is to
[ __ ] snuggle up ha dude there's the
first magic pillow dude and your dress
yeah well they're dressed like 2/3 of a
magic trick - have you ever seen those
old ones where they put the cape over
you walk around like Darth Vader and
[ __ ] it's like dude I met them all
they're all wonderful people yes really
that stop stop [ __ ] thinking this
group is evil in that group I don't
think that many people think that I
think there's some on education where
some people are like you know but I
don't think these days there's that many
people that are growing up thinking like
oh [ __ ] that group of people
wholeheartedly well the thing is like
when you when someone is like that the
algorithms on social media push them
forward and it sounds like it's
everybody
yeah but the algorithms want that to
happen to like sorry mommy go to war the
news wins like the news wins if there's
a war but where you gonna go you're
gonna go back to the news and now the
news yeah look I'm not saying I know I
mean I'm just as much a victim of of
advertising and of all of it like you
know like I mean you know one day I feel
one way and one day I question what what
my feelings are you know it's but it's
definitely that's a good segue for an ad
read so right now we have that's perfect
today's episode is brought to you by the
always classy Ridge wallet and a lot of
people you think about a ridge like oh
what is a rich I don't know somebody say
I don't know I don't know and then you
think about a wallet and now you have
what I'm talking about
Ridge wallet
you know a wallet is something someone
keep in the back of their pants but
those days are over man think about the
past that's what you're doing
so ridge wallet it's it's that front
pocket carry it's the future you know
put your money where your motion is
going forward put your money to the
front and that's what a Ridge wallet
does it has a special case that you know
you can put your credit cards in there
get your identification
get your little money in there if you
want it and move forward you can go to
Ridge wallet comm slash tpw and use code
tpw at checkout for 10%
that's code tpw for 10% off at Ridge
Wallet comm /t PW go on and get it a lot
of podcasts are brought to you by
different stuff and this one is brought
to you by skill share skill share is an
online learning community for creators
creators with more than 25,000 classes
in design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity does your curiosity have any
fuel or is just milling around aimless
like a dirty dirty fire you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career on Skillshare you
can take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle or gain new
professional skills Skillshare is there
to keep you learning thriving and
reaching those new goals join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for our listeners you can get two
months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare a place to learn skills
is offering this past weekend listeners
two months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free free to sign up
go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to ski
sher calm / Theo von to start your two
months now that Skillshare dot-com /
Theo von but yeah I don't know man what
do you guys think do you guys are
[ __ ] alive Nick my question is how do
you discern which sources you trust like
what do you listen to what do you watch
and it like because there are conspiracy
theorists who are like whack jobs and
then that that muddies the waters of
possible truth so how do you find it
first of all never trust anybody hole
hardly anything you hear from me I hope
you will check and check and recheck if
you uh if if you history you study the
history of your best ability and then
you find who gets the money who gets the
power you're probably onto something
okay but in 2013 oh they realized with
the internet they couldn't control it so
in 2013 Obama passed a law in which the
US government could legally now they did
before but legally use propaganda
against the US population and that's
what they did they say oh we can't
control it so we're gonna flood it and
they just flooded with information
coming both [ __ ] waste now there are
just some people out there that I just
believe ah that are gonna spit the truth
the whole truth nothing but the truth
like james corbett like anything that
guy says still research but i'm like
he's telling the truth
ah you know um who else is there ryan
Dawson like that guys out there spitting
the truth you know what you don't thing
right I was thinking Ryan Gosling you
should question everybody all the time
referenced back and forth and if it
lines up money power and history you're
probably on to something do you think
it's interesting there's sometimes it's
like if I find I don't know if I do this
but it's easy for us to once you find
news or whatever that fits with what
your views are and you just MIT then
those well that's why you have Fox News
and MSNBC because they tell you what you
want to hear yeah my girlfriend can't
stop watching MSNBC do you know it's
like to do a conspiracy podcast and come
home and have your girlfriend watching
MSNBC that's like working for coca-cola
and come home and
your girlfriend's just drinking Pepsi
you're like I'm paying the bills and
you're [ __ ] drinking the competitors
it's total [ __ ] but it's like you
get hooked on hearing what you its echo
chamber [ __ ] it is really hard to hear
an opposing view opposing view and be
open to maybe they got a point
well it's also be hard to not become an
echo chamber by just like getting your
thoughts and then you hear what you want
to hear you go to a place that's
familiar to hear something and then you
don't question it anymore and so then
you start it's like it's hard for us not
to become echo chambers man for sure
really really hard like I have these
things called the rules of the Ronin
right Ronin were masterless samurai they
were master of core of the art and they
had no hoo-hah and they had no master so
it's kind of I do first of all you don't
defend anybody you don't personally no
you don't defend any action you were
personally a part of you are part of no
group you're no group nobody you know
like I'm a Democrat you're not part of
any yeah that's done anyway I feel like
I feel like people just wholeheartedly
like you don't give information of those
who do not seek it yeah and that you
follow that rule you just gonna save you
so much [ __ ] stop trying to educate
people when they don't want to hear it
and then you write the wrongs when you
see a like [ __ ] depression and and
people [ __ ] just cracking skulls and
other people you try to stand up and
push against it but if you follow those
basic rules that you're not part of a
group you don't defend anyone you don't
know you don't defend any action you
weren't part of you'll be [ __ ] fine
yeah and [ __ ] blue checks I won't get
blue checks by my name that system is
all put together so that um AI can spin
like they start seeing you you're saying
certain words they like then they give
you a blue check and then they just
start tweeting and retweeting and make
it seem like a bunch of people behind
you and they're not really it's all AI
that's all yeah and that's only see like
some of these young comics coming in LA
and they start buying into this social
justice warrior [ __ ] and they start
saying dumb [ __ ] like [ __ ] white guys
all the time yeah and they get all these
things they think people like that no
it's AI just [ __ ] making it seem like
everyone's getting behind you and
they're not I know comic who went crazy
he's living way
in the milk nowhere because he started
falling for these tweets and these
retweets yeah and they weren't real and
he just went nuts because of these
tweets and retweets those aren't real
things it's crazy how yeah that kind of
stuff can yeah it's like I mean it's
wild man as well to think that that
these that there's Jessie is crazy oh
dude I was watching a video the other
day about AI and it said it was like we
put our best brains like in different
games it was about poker and then it was
about what else was it was poker was
this game called go it's like a Chinese
game and there was one other Oh in chess
right and the only one that humans
really had a chance on was the poker
because every now and then a person
could do something that was you couldn't
really calculate you know how about the
chess they made moves up they have never
been seen before in like the hundred
years of chess yeah like yet a Wizards
nobody that a wizard came onto the board
at one point and two hookers we're
hiding minor rook that's what I heard
look if you want to get involved in any
of you want to know what is behind the
shadows if you want to know what the
what ingredients are the recipes in the
shadows tinfoil hat is your podcast Sam
Tripoli and your and Ryan is your
co-host no Ryan left a while ago
I now have XG and the place to be we are
celebrating our 200th Eddie Bravo who's
gonna be our 200th and that's coming up
we have big shows coming up with David
Icke who's like the og of this stuff
damn yeah like do we have some amazing
things come out with me you guys have
some great thinkers man you guys are
like it's not I don't want to say it's
counterculture but it's I think it's
becoming more and more particles for
that world I'm not judge and it look man
I mean I'm intrigued yet every time I
see you always are like you know person
that's like uplifting and fun to talk to
and definitely talking about unique
stuff yeah I'm trying to bring to the
stage now too so it's really I'm
enjoying it dude it's a nice lane it's
like what vice used to be a vice so now
marina you're like [ __ ] these guys are
great I love that [ __ ] it's the unn
reported dude that's what I talk about
it's not conspiracies well I know the
New Moon I'll never know well I know
about earth is flat or not I've done no
[ __ ] research I was told it was it
was round
I say it's round because I got told that
I've done no research into it and I'll
never do any research because it's
beyond me and any of that [ __ ]
yeah we live in a simulation dude you
can control your destiny right just like
any video game there's rules to it like
Super Mario can't turn to a dragon and
kick [ __ ] King Kong's ass a donkey
kong's ass but he can still get to
different levels you can do different
levels you can still achieve if you just
realize you're control
dude The Matrix was a documentary that's
my opinion
hmm I love that man Wow we're [ __ ]
deep in here now oh I know
I feel like ice I [ __ ] you make
everybody weird but do you know no I
don't think so I think it's interesting
you make me wonder you know you make me
wonder you make me wonder if I'm naive
naive yeah hmm nothing you are never
trust people
you mean wonder if I'm naive if I'm not
homosexual but um no I think if I was
gay I would have done it by now
yeah okay I think your sexuality should
be about as important as your work yeah
not just because I think [ __ ] a lot
of these dudes are [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
okay maybe there's a nice guy with a
nice dick in that hahahaha I'm not
saying that man I'm just saying you know
you know I got my own dick but yeah
that's wrong yeah I mean think about it
every guy has jerked off themselves
enough that that's you could be
considered gay you've jerked off enough
that's true
you definitely imagine yeah dude if
anybody else did something to this many
times to themself do you feel like all
that if an animal is in this so many
chicks as you [ __ ]
you still haven't been in it as many
vaginas as you've jerked yourself off so
sad to throw in my hand if I even
actually just even bring my hand near my
penis I feel so much shame really why I
don't know I just have so much shame
about I have so much shame around sex I
don't know what it is man it's wonderful
yeah I think well you
when I was young I used to go to the
library and uh which is now coming to a
homeless person adult bookstore I mean
they just straight up stroking in and
they can't stop it by legally they can
watch porn they're just you know they
stopped a guy from a black eye the other
day from jerking off at the library and
they accused him [ __ ] racist
librarians who were both black it's just
chaos out there but dude I remember
that's how I would learn all these
rubenesque pictures you know like a lot
of the famous rubenesque artists you
know and I would go look at their work
and like jerk off into the books or I
would remember getting erect close the
book on my penis as hard as I could
until I would write like no or like slow
it's not erection into warrior dude it's
just regular I'm just talking about I'm
talking about slow pressure man a slow
build brother no [ __ ] sweat my wiener
in a book like some weird [ __ ] dudes
like they get kicked in the balls
yeah one of my buddy of mine his he
would have his girlfriend take a cup of
coins up to there they had like a
rooftop balcony poured off the balcony
who is it
what do you just tell me that people do
strange stuff I tell you something
strange and you say I'm crazy guy no
dude I'm blown away we have just gone
beyond the mating process
we're just what turn nephew done by
raining nickels I think he live by Wells
Fargo man yeah no idea bro or I think he
worked right next to the coin store of
one of those del champs oh yeah that
sound maybe we got off on like being at
casinos here and all that that [ __ ]
Jay King slot machine [ __ ] ching ching
ching yeah well the crazy thing is - and
how racially [ __ ] up it is if you see
a Chinese person cinema chain and the
Machine is sitting there just telling
him [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] over and over
again how [ __ ] up is that
I'm against it I'm tired of race a slot
machine oh you'd imagine yeah that's my
new movement
what if you're sitting there and it's
just like wiggle wiggle
we got fix fix big big jiù jiù jiù jiù
never tell you Holly Paul Mooney called
me the n-word uh-uh
is he dizzy qualifies bike - he's kind
of white Paul Mooney it's kind of white
I haven't seen it's working oh wait I've
seen one special you don't know seen
black
I'm Richard Pryor yeah yeah oh then I'm
nothing I'm cleaning - somebody you
think that Paul Giamatti I'm not sure
one thing you know maybe Peter Paul and
Mary I don't know dude I was doing a
joke about how I how hard to be a white
guy came up to me it's like Oh homie you
ain't white you saw meaning use it [ __ ]
I was like and two states the number one
credit out my Wikipedia did [ __ ]
proud of that [ __ ] I love that man yeah
Palmer he's a legend dude I know he
wrote for Richard I know you wrote for
Richard Pryor yeah I do Wow did you ever
meet Richard Pryor nope you ever see him
perform nope me neither
he I regret it him and don don rickles
are the two people I will love this
scene live I know I was about to buy the
ticket cuz he's played in southern
County
we all go sometime homeboy when you die
man do you think you remember anything
that's happened here okay so when you
die right mm-hmm
you you're gonna be met by people who
look like your loved ones they are not
your loved ones those are archons and
their job is to get you back into light
where you were reborn because you are a
energy battery force right so it's just
a trick of your brain yes Wow no it's a
trick of the afterlife but so it's a
mechanist a safety mechanism really now
safety mechanism it's a [ __ ]
straight-up hoodwink but is it a but it
but okay I'm gonna tell you somebody
value in the hood wing because there's a
moon have you ever studied the moon yeah
okay tell me about the moon the moon
yeah does not make any sense well hold
on you said tell you about the moon you
didn't give us a chance to I would say
this tell us about the moon um I think
it seems very like kind of
kind of um like the moon I'm thinking
about the moon the moon's like you know
sometimes it's cool sometimes it's not
it's got moods
yeah moody yeah the moon is Moody the
mood they should call it the mood what's
very interesting is that the moon its
orbit is unlike anything else in the
universe oh yeah it hurt it goes there's
no wobbling it goes perfectly in the
same orbit and we see the same side
every time it doesn't make any sense
it's bigger than Pluto why is it there
it doesn't make any sense there's
there's times the moon is kind of
[ __ ] dude when you think about the
moon think about the moon bro what yeah
there's something dis up there for no
reason
so milling around dude it's like a child
it's like the Earth's little [ __ ]
shitty child some people think it's
hollow and some people think it's an
energy it's our energy why I could see
when you die you get absorbed into the
moon and that's what happened so now
let's take a look at pac-man right you
ever played the game pac-man when
pac-man's mouth is closed what does it
look like the [ __ ] moon and was it do
it eats eats eats eats right so these
ghosts are chasing the moon are the
ghosts chasing moon when he eats the
ghosts what happened it goes back to the
regenerator and it's reborn dude it's
the exact same story read the [ __ ]
Tibetan Book of the Dead that's exactly
what it's about that's exactly what the
matrix is telling you about dude we are
batteries for the archons and lizard
people now I did something for the CW
comes out in July and we do something on
the Montauk Project from Montauk is that
where orc Steven Avery no that's not
Steven everywhere is that Manitowoc yeah
that's man tois that's a whole different
thing and that dude got framed I don't
care what anyone says
really oh for sure dude that guy
definitely did it bro no I'll say this
fat Brendan
his little nephew or whatever's little
buddy his little [ __ ] fire buddy Oh
y-yeah no way there's no way he did it
he called Theresa how back like 35 times
mrs. Loren his yard no sense dude this
new lawyer [ __ ] nailed it man why
would somebody who dinner why would they
care that much about stopping Steven
Avery that dude the guy worked at a
junkyard he had a machine that crushes
[ __ ] cars
you just killed somebody why wouldn't
you crush that [ __ ] car why would you
put it somewhere with branches over it
like this is a hanna-barbera [ __ ]
cartoon like what are we Bugs Bunny yeah
scooby-doo and the gang gonna find the
[ __ ] car toys
zoid-zoid I would run away with it
wasn't for you pesky kids
so it's Brenda you know you met Boykin
police yeah you meddling Sheboygan
police
so so that's yeah that's okay what about
your boy Adnan Syed that guy did thank
you dude that girl Sarah Koenig is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how do you not think the guy did it
every time he's on the phone he's pretty
much like yeah I did it but you know
what's so interesting I think he's
convinced himself yes no hundred percent
people I knew that they can part my eyes
things that and when they say I didn't
do it they've actually convinced
themselves they didn't do it so when I
was young they have to we used to
terrorize this convenience store right
and I watch this one guy's name a buddy
of mine a Middle Eastern guy terrorizing
a convenience who's Middle Eastern
during the norms you are aren't you
you just said you were from the caucus
moans that's Christian to caucus of what
the collagen yeah Caucasian from Asian
Oh perfect a half row but where the
caucus mountains
caucus mounds are like even like Eastern
Europe oh yeah you know we're white dog
gang right gang [ __ ] let's go to a
question right here man okay go to a
question I'm sorry right now this is
funny
your hands the yovan Sam trips we out
here
dark parking lot in New Jersey waiting
to pick up some of that reefer
I want to hear any stories you guys got
about going to get some of that
contraband let me know these gang do why
why it's so weird that one part of the
soil is this as an illegal activity this
other part of the soil it's a totally
legal activity so much more fun who sit
in a parking lot looking like he's up
yeah about to do a [ __ ] backyard
abortion he's like just for some weed
bro
how much more fun is it like this guy so
much more fun what about the first time
you guys bought weed Nick or Gianni um I
was in eighth grade and I got caught you
did yeah by whom by my friend's mom
because and then we I bought it and they
were gonna resell it and then we got
caught and then they called my parents
but my older brother pretended to be my
parents and then I had to buy him a pair
of oakley sunglasses that is so funny
it's Christian brother praise God
brother you're just a young Christian
warrior now I don't remember
picking up like the first time but I do
remember the first time we try to get
high we were just scraping a guy's older
brother's ball and just doing rez hits
and it just smelled like [ __ ] I was like
I don't know if this is for me until
years later and then it was yeah but
yeah I mean they all essentially look
like this guy who's dark parking lot
waiting for way too long 50 calls and
tax like where is he just hand me the
money dude it was so much fun bro
dude we got high my buddy Jeff was
sitting in a Ford Ranger which was like
the gayest truck you could have and
still be a straight guy remember that
the little one no extended-cab
forget picking her that Ford Ranger like
1995 it was so small bro you could if it
got windy you had to stop you had to
pull over dude and only a small small
stepdad could drive it dude your real
dad would never drive it with stepdads
only
and my buddy Jeff Soviet was sitting in
there and he was smoking as much weed as
a human could smoke man because he was
in I think like emotionally disabled
class and uh the car was filled with
smoke which is the funnest thing to do
just get so much weed smoking that you
couldn't see out of the car right and
his mom pulled up and that she's like
where's Jeff dude my only job was to say
haven't seen him right yeah but the
other part of my job was also to say oh
just right over there in that truck it
was like it was like the beginning of
like an Edgar Allan Poe movie or some
bro
it's like Ichabod Crane just coming
through the coming through the
Horseman's yes yes awesome man
and from that moment on I was like I
don't know how high I'm gonna get but
I'm making to make sure that everybody
else gets high around funny is that it's
like that was like her walk am smoking
crack like that was like we crack same
[ __ ] same kind drug you go to some
[ __ ] camp and programs and [ __ ] kids
got taken out of school where they're
supposed to be learning it building her
career just because they were smoking
some weed yeah and then they ended up a
plant literally something from the
ground and then ended up doing construed
you're getting into some job or doing
becoming murderers like mom because they
spoke to joy in eighth grade and their
life was then same dude I will never
forget man the time just get just
waiting for weed picking it up being so
scared so scared bro what was the first
time you bought me I think I remember
buying it off a some guy and then trying
to sell it like you said like
immediately I wanted to be the
businessman and the deal you know gonna
burn oh I had four joints I was gonna
sell three and a half of them you know
so now I'm driving around my
neighborhood trying to get people to buy
this [ __ ] sweating in my car thinking
everybody's an undercover cop dude over
one time a [ __ ] car alarm went off
and I got so I laid facedown on my
driveway like this was my hands [ __ ]
behind my head
dude just so scared thinking everybody
was trying to bust meanwhile dude I
remember I made like $11 and I quit
selling drugs that same day left up dude
most people yeah dude my next-door
neighbor is like a six year old crack
dealer dude Wow dude man to be in the
game at six think god bless you bro
that's some Brett Farve [ __ ] what about
you Sam do you remember I smoked weed at
my friend Eldorado's house yeah of
course they told me is oregano and it
was a joke and then they're like dude
it's weed I'm like you still blame them
at all what about ruining my life yeah
no I did I think I ruined my own life
yeah respect man let's get another
question they came in for saying the
things so interesting about weed is like
people like it was legal I would do it
it's like why do you let that decide you
what is right and wrong most laws are
passed obviously outside of like murder
rape violence and stealing outside of
it's mostly about what helps rich people
get richer yeah [ __ ] legal or not legal
is it right or is it wrong common sense
smoke weed have fun who gives a [ __ ]
you can drink alcohol and pop [ __ ]
oxycottons legally but you can't [ __ ]
smoke weed I can own a gun and be on
adderall but I can't own a gun and smoke
weed do you know why rappers ruin
[ __ ] everything dude who can shot on
wheat rappers yeah what else they ruin
people's nicest people in the world dude
everything's have pitbull at the pound
why cuz they're smooth criminals oh yeah
you don't get to not get everybody
pregnant without being smooth Oh watch
it if we had a pitbull came to town
watching them [ __ ] but we drive our
bikes all over time to watch them [ __ ]
yeah oh oh
guys got pitbull Wolverine just watch it
[ __ ] a bird or a single [ __ ] whatever
dude [ __ ] a basketball my buddies hug
held down their sister and let the dog
just hump it yeah that girl is better
for out bro and that's a Betsy Ross yeah
make the flag the flag was originally a
jizz rag knows that this one's audio
only oh [ __ ]
what up deal Gang Gang baby okay I'm uh
I'm on my lunch break right now and saw
on your Instagram that mr. sim Tripoli
is gonna be on this week got a question
for him Sam loved the podcast huge tent
foil half and I just want to know man
have you ever believed or followed a
conspiracy theory that was maybe a
little bit too outlandish for your
friends that they kind of cut ties with
you and ended a friendship that I'm
wondering if folks ever dealt with that
so how'd you handle it you gentlemen
ever listen um much love for you guys
love everything you do Gang Gang Gang
bro Thank You second out man gang yeah
Sam that's a good question man is there
a place where it's sometimes it's too
deep for you do you have a too deep I
mean there's certain things I'm not
gonna go into just because I feel like
what's the result of that right you know
so I don't go into that but you know
it's like I had hands put on me at The
Comedy Store about the Clintons running
a pedophile Network which is 100% true
and people put hands on me and either
put hands on them to tell them not to do
it but people just get weird man because
they pick teams and like you know me
dude a lot of people you don't know
Hillary yeah but you're defending
Hillary over someone it's like been your
friend for [ __ ] years that's the
weirdest [ __ ] yeah if Hillary like was
there and you were there and you're like
tall and you guys had different story
I'd be like I know feel I'm a belief
feel right I'm a person that's a good
point yeah why is it that we get so
attached and that's the thing they say
not to talk about all the times it's
politics but why is it that we get so
people will go to their graves about
that kind of stuff because they won you
know it's not in the conspiracies people
who are super successful and people who
have kids and the reason they hey
they're not a conspiracy super
successful people because they don't
want to have to be like Oh am i aiding
and abetting into this [ __ ] or do I have
to stop the gravy train and pay
attention what's going on and then with
kids they don't want to think about kids
bringing their kids into this awful
world
and that's just the truth and it's just
like I get it man it's scary but if the
world is a magical place - it really is
and I tell people man imagine every
movie ever made ever all going on at one
time that's reality
Wow there are so much [ __ ] going on that
people don't even understand it's such a
beautiful magical world magic you know
real magic goes on [ __ ] controlling
all the [ __ ] I mean it's dude is
everyone yeah and people want to focus
on all the one weird negative [ __ ] that
the that the news wants to tell you it's
like that's just 2d [ __ ] man
there's 5d [ __ ] going on oh yeah and you
could love it and that's you know so
like the Clintons are the big thing I
lost a lot of friends and it's just
weird did ya people creeped me I think
ever since I started doing conspiracies
I've been on a lot less podcast really
yeah I'm glad that we had you here today
man
you think it's still possible to rob
from the rich and give to the poor do
you think it's still possible for sure
how do you do what you think I'm not
gonna give away my my plan because then
you have uh nothing I mean I know I'm
not gonna grab from the rich I'm just
gonna I'm telling you a Bitcoin dog
Bitcoin get out of the banking system
I just bought some I think a couple
coins of levitra earlier today well
there's too many coins some blue too big
what is that stuff
dude I want come up with a [ __ ] weed
cannabis [ __ ] boner pill caught high
and hard dog and just will make all the
money oh my god bro dude I would get
some when I used to get high get some of
crazy erections yeah I brought I get an
erection it would undo my pants for me
huh dude is Max's once I was so hot
who's this crazy guy yeah yeah I fall
asleep my dick woke me up said somewhere
to be so you know when Chris Hardwick
got some [ __ ] his ex-girlfriend
[ __ ] we all and all these sellout
[ __ ] through that dude under
the bus when he's the nicest guy and he
got so many people there first credit
[ __ ] all you sellout punk-ass [ __ ]
right and his girlfriend's like his
ex-girlfriend's like he is to make me
have sex why didn't want to I guess
sounds like a relationship right like I
used to dude I used to get sleep boner
still do I woke up
like three times ex-girlfriends riding
two just riding cuz they like I used to
rock sleep owners yeah I about dude the
best part about turning how old are you
31 okay you guys got time yeah man when
you turn 40 your body does just it just
overthrows the dictator right right cuz
your dick used to make all the calls it
was one mo and you mean dude I do day
your age I used to drive like 70 miles
to get laid oh yeah oh dude I remember
if I would still have our children's
bike female children's bike in my
neighborhood to [ __ ] get laid I don't
yeah and that's when I was told about 26
years of hold a male bike does this and
the female bike does that but uh oh I
don't know it's your question it's like
if my nuts are gonna get hit yeah bikes
are dangerous dude bikes are dangerous
but I would I would weigh whether dying
in a bike accident to me caught dead
wearing a [ __ ] bike helmet and even
though I have a girlfriend dude I always
do what I call [ __ ] math on the road
yeah like just like you know some girl
wants some action I just like calculate
in my head like how much time nephron
I'd have to put in to this chick versus
a burrito
burritos undefeated dog undefeated for
do you know always always wins in a
burrito
go home sleep that's good man that
sounds really good I wish I had a
burrito maker in here dude I hear you
got another room yeah we do we're thing
about doing lemonade or something there
what else do we have we have another guy
in the dark obviously yeah you don't
like this man you're bringing people out
do you consider yourself an
investigative journalist yes yeah I got
called an independent reporter the other
day by a very high up guy I was like wow
that's coolest things so this huge guy
named David Icke suppose come on we're
gonna have to reschedule him for the 26
but he's like I've been watching your
show man it's very entertaining I'm like
damn the top dogs are watching that's
cool it is cool yeah it's only this
whole that all of us is only gonna grow
like I mean even us doing podcasts in
here man it's like you know we can talk
about different stuff and we don't
nobody owns us that's the thing it's
like nobody like I was in I don't get
why you keep wanting to do TV
I don't not I'm saying that I want to do
TV do it
you do it's like dude hey hey can I go
back on the plantation police it's like
you've escaped the plantation stop going
back I did the weather channel once ride
because I love the Weather Channel
cuz all the other female like weather
ladies all look like they do like Dog
Fart porn which is like a interracial
gangbang porn they got that crazy stare
in their eyes right yeah that night it's
all like murder but based on the weather
like it was a balmy day I'm murder right
hey I like I'm like oh cool I'm gonna go
do it I show up man my call time is 8:30
which is already pushing it I get there
I don't record to like 11 and my buddy
does a podcast he's like this is why we
do podcasts man and like I just did some
for the CW and the Biasi oh it was
wonderful experience because it was like
so rich that what I'm doing TV you're
just describing one episode about the
Montauk Project conspiracies dude but
outside of that man I show up and sit on
set no [ __ ] man I'm doing TV this right
here today well you do you like you and
Sakura keep trying to get TV shows I'm
like nothing
[ __ ] plantation you don't need to go
back well I guess we hit what they I do
think about is well we made you a show
that's based on this podcast that's fine
but this I'm like dude to me it's like
what is the easiest way right like dude
you do TV show it's like I wanna show up
and get the [ __ ] out I think if it's
someone something that really shows
steals personality it can open them up
to a new audience who isn't familiar
with podcast and you bring them into the
fold there's some money to it but it's
like you're free at last free Atlanta
thank god this podcast is here cuz
you're free last yeah I was in a meeting
this morning they're talking about doing
you know they go we would love to do
this we look and I was just thinking
myself I said and I even said I said
yeah the thing is though like if I do
something and then what if I say
something on my podcast and somebody
says something about it or makes a deal
about it and then suddenly the you know
the show's gone everybody's angry or
something it's my fault and it was
nothing it's nothing that would have
been anything but just because it's like
they can't bring you down if you don't
let them bring you up dude
you have your own pirate ship dude yeah
you can raid [ __ ] I will have
four big names nothing happened because
they got my own pirate ship yeah I'm not
saying you don't want do TV butts like a
lot of work we came oh yeah yeah that
stuff seems like a lot of work not man I
don't want to stay outta like you know I
mean this is what I love to do you know
and this is you know but I would like I
mean I think about sometimes it would be
an artistic way to do like a movie or
something crazy like an eastbound and
down type of move like remember that
fist foot way or whatever he did oh yeah
or something that would be really cool
to do with your friends like what's a
neat way that we could still be artistic
and do something different movies are
different though man movies are like
it's an experience television is just
it's just oh some of that just seems
horrible now I would do a show with
Roseanne I would like to I mean I
thought that broke in interview that was
like oh right yeah man I mean she was
hard like he'd ask questions she'd ask
answer a different question I like watch
I'm like do Brogan's putting in time
yeah like he was doing his best to make
her look good and she's great but man
that was a lot of work yeah yeah um all
right let's get another question here
this guy right here
beautiful soldiers I figured I would ask
this question since Sam's in there today
and this is surrounded by conspiracies
first one Sam I'd really like to get
your opinion on Jim Morrison if you
really believe that he was involved in
all of this back in the day and another
thing
speaking on conspiracies hashtag deep
okay Jim Morrison's father was involved
with the gulf of tonkin which is a giant
false flag to bring us into Vietnam and
Vietnam was not about communism Vietnam
was about getting the opium fields of
Vietnam which is like very plush for
opium so his father was very much in and
what you see within like Hollywood is a
lot of military brats very high up in
top positions he so when I say there's
no such thing as culture there's no such
thing as culture it is programming by
the highest levels they use they they
use their assets to basically create
the feel for what would be culture so
you know it's like when you look at like
Jim Morrison his father was very high up
in the military and then he created that
Laurel Canyon studio which was all
military brats controlled by the CIA
I've been up there
so that I so I just had the Grateful
Dead near my house because I live near
the bowl and I want to go and harass all
those people because you're literally
like this the Grateful Dead was CIA they
are all CIA they were [ __ ] the guy
who made all their acid for the CIA the
Grateful Dead was their house band
well yeah did if I'm want to ask that I
don't have them as my house man yeah but
do I mean the point is that ass to CIA
we think they were working with the CIA
oh yeah they were that's also a time I
feel like when everybody was working
with the CIA it's like literally if you
had a vehicle CIA was giving funny and
asking a question through the crazy
things like you know who was their
manager for a short long time Courtney
Love Courtney Love's dad was the manager
of the Grateful Dead and if you go work
he loved his his Courtney Love Corey
love corn grow up Nirvana's ex-wife yes
and if you get into her and her she's
like dude I better put those like a bomb
went off near it and that's and I don't
mean that she used it as [ __ ] dude she's
a lot of people say she killed the guy
she had him kill dude look into it dude
100% and I wouldn't be surprised
she has there's something wrong with her
she's got a couple the truth is man
she's born to world she has two parents
who didn't [ __ ] protect her and she's
thrown into a mental facility a very
young and they are used an abuser and
they turned her into a CIA asset and her
job was to go around the different
[ __ ] ah musical scenes and spread
drugs and acid to everybody everybody
yeah I'm like your kid but when you're a
hot chick I mean that's what you use use
the power of s see the odd MKULTRA
program they use to to you if you're man
women you get used for different stuff
women get you they call them a sex
kittens and they're used as sex kids and
they use sex to control people and then
we're men are turning to Assassins Jesus
Christ dude you know what also had I was
just like that
place howl at the moon you ever been to
one of those places with it yeah
sing-along [ __ ] yeah
piano bar oh my god who's [ __ ] I
should assassinate bars or CIA howl at
the moon come on think about that think
about that
yeah Larry Howell if you don't know look
it up Larry Howell his grandfather used
to sell some cement to a Guyot see yeah
I love it man putting together the
pieces what's the rest of this one that
was it that was it that was it you
didn't have anything else oh wow very
interesting man Oh Sam I don't even know
you're like that wild fish you catch and
like holy [ __ ] you're supposed to catch
this or we now those sketches do we tell
the we'll make everybody uncomfortable
they only want to talk conspiracies and
I know the [ __ ] listeners are gonna
be weird about it I can talk anything no
I don't feel like that do you feel like
we only talked about conspiracies not at
all and also by the way our audience
loves Eddie Bravo or we've had him on
twice two of our biggest episodes oh
he's the best he's such a G and he's a
little lover yeah yeah he's a sweet guy
man he's such a nice guy haven't seen
him a little bit I wish I would see him
more often I gotta go he's just a
hustler dude he does stand up and he
[ __ ] dude if that guy tried he'd be the
funniest dude out there if he actually
sat down and did I mean dude he tells
stories I'm like do did you just riff
that it's like yeah I'm like that's the
funniest story I've ever heard in my
life yeah he would crush cue go we go on
the road we're like okay do-do 30 40
minutes later I'm like come on what am I
gonna tell the guy that could choke
everybody else to get the [ __ ] off stage
and then go up and crying dude I'm
telling you man he's a mu on the road
dude it's like I get like Bert Kreischer
laughs at my shelves yeah I'm like this
must be what it's like to be Bert
Kreischer people love you man
no one in tinfoil hats they love me in
regular shows I got watch where I go and
perform now yeah because what I'm
talking about is not for the stupid yeah
I see the are it's really not that's one
thing that's interesting about the whole
universe that you're in that you that
tinfoil hat is in is it's not for the
stupid it's not
and it's just like I just did this West
Side comedy club which is a great club I
followed this one kid just crushing so
funny and I went up and it was just like
I just went wrong hole on this crowd oh
yeah
and for 50 minutes they just stared at
me yeah one for the point where I just
gave all the money I made it to the
staff I'm like you keep it I don't even
want that blood money dude
went for the button they only had two
mouths yeah then go to store did the
same act crush oh dude I remember when I
was on mushrooms and I did a set of The
Improv right and it went pretty well so
a lot of people don't know that after
that I went and did a set at The Comedy
Store and there was a man in like the
second row that was in a wheelchair oh
and that's where they have them you know
wheelchairs you see him a lot of times
handicapped people are in him this you
see them once in a while yeah yeah so
anyway I was so [ __ ] up bro and I kept
thought I was hearing his this guy was
saying something right I kept thought he
was saying something to me what was
happening was it was some squeaky thing
on his chair and he had like a thing
whenever he would shake a little they
would make the squeak but I kept
thinking that was him [ __ ] with me
right so four minutes into the cassette
bro all I can hear is everything in the
whole [ __ ] world right I'm just real
[ __ ] up so I call him out I'm like
what the [ __ ] is your problem dude it's
just a guy in a wheelchair
yeah who is done nothing his whole life
except not walk around and probably
being nice to people he was like my legs
dude I are one Pro and for the next
seven minutes I accuse that guy because
every time I'd stop the thing would go
he would do it would happen again
it was insane bro and I didn't realize
till the end when I got down all our
friends are dying laughing back no one
else would laugh the whole time I was so
scared and like man that guy there's a
hit a squeaky wheel chair that's one
time I was at the store and you walk in
and I always go hey to the to the you
know the door guy or the cashier how's
it going and they're like dude it's real
weird
I go why goes well there's a blind guy
in the crowd and he's heckling everybody
and I'm like oh [ __ ] so I watched up and
he's heckling Jeff Richards and Jeff's
just sitting there eating dicks on stage
and then Bret Ernst goes up but he
starts to stand up and this guy yells
you're not funny and Bret's about to
jump a bit like he's blind breast like
oh I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry I'm like if this guy
heckles me come on like this mother did
you get his information cuz we really
want a blind guy yeah we're done again
someone is blind I don't even know when
he was I'm sure you'll find a blind guy
so I go up and wouldn't think so but I
get here dude yeah well we've been
looking for a year-and-a-half row blind
I do think we have a blind lady on tap I
just got to show you I think it's a real
possibility okay so I go up there I'm
like doing stand-up and also he's like
you're not funny and dude I unleash on
this dude I'm like you're [ __ ]
annoying
nobody cares you're blind they all want
pushing put you towards traffic ahead
and walk in traffic he's laughing his
wife [ __ ] chirps at me I'm like I go
blind - five - look here old wrinkled
[ __ ] all the time
everybody half the rooms going crazy
half the people are hating me when I get
done dude and my whole act is ripping
this new door [ __ ]
I get offstage he comes out and takes
pictures with Wow
he's like finally somebody told me shut
the [ __ ] up I'm like yeah dawg
that's how we do it and that's everybody
patty-cake singing they just won't be
people do yeah well the craziest sights
I ever had is I had to do rule I had to
do like the Special Olympics at the cop
at The Improv oh yeah special people
yeah and they were heckling me dude
you're like they love dick jokes by
special people laugh when you're
handicapped your dick is everything oh
well dude they got that [ __ ] strength
and [ __ ] dude and it's just I would just
cuz they have this hot handler just like
hot and I would just talk about all the
weird [ __ ] and you just see them like
flipping around in their wheelchair like
dude and loving it just goes to show you
the power of laughter that somebody they
can be mentally impaired physically
impaired and laughter will still
permeate them make them say we're
drinking bro like special people with
[ __ ] bud wires doing a KERS bro dude
I used to drink with a kid
my neighborhood this kid dairy growing
up we used to drink alcohol and he had
Down syndrome you know we're Down
syndrome but I'll say this dude um
[ __ ] man were we talking about I don't
remember we're talking about man but uh
handicapped people just want to be like
everybody else
yeah yeah do you not think more the way
you are different so were strippers yeah
we all just want to be strippers are
grade two I've ever been on uh said that
Nickelback do they mm-hm there you go
we'll all just want to be Nickelback man
well a lot of subtext in this one
brother I love it I love it - man thank
you so much for coming in and hanging
out with this man please check out my
special go to Sam Tripoli comm look up
Sam Tripoli stand with special Sam
specifically specials there's two of
them ones are mo get in it's my
Christmas album and then the other one
is zero Fox zero [ __ ] YouTube is [ __ ]
with everything it's hard to find but
you'll find it what about uh well we'll
link it below to you on our and we'll
talk about right in the beginning yeah
whenever we do the intro for you Sam
Tripoli ladies and gentlemen I love you
do they'll be glad your YouTube shows
blown up
did you inspire I don't even know people
knew this you will told me one day like
hey man you got to start doing YouTube
clips do you mean you said look man you
gotta you made me download this app and
it was called a video shop yeah I said
you got to download this app and you got
to make a clip and you put it onto
YouTube and that's what you got to do
and I was like alright dude you did you
all right man I'll try it and boom look
at you now
selling out Australia yeah man it's
crazy and I remember the first one I
made was about oh after the election I
said that bald eagles there was a black
market for bald eagles anyway I was kind
of boring the beginning was the
beginning of greatness man I'm gonna be
doing some more rants on mine but yeah
did you listen to me and it blew up I
did took your advice and I always will
man that's probably no remember to look
into it you know I got Tom Segura in the
stand up
did you really I'm the reason he does
stand up
no way yeah dude that's awesome
it's the I he [ __ ] we were in the same
growling class you ever meet somebody so
funny you're like don't really know him
so no no but like in life you meet
somebody so funny you're like either we
could be friends or we could be like
gun-slinging you know who's got the like
I'd pick friendship cuz I want to just
because I won't be the fastest gun and I
need a fast got on my clock that guy's a
fast gun right he's such a funny guy man
so I went up to him I go dude you're
really funny should try stamp he's like
I don't know what it is I'm like follow
me and for a week I took him and showed
him how to do stand-up and now he's like
[ __ ] huge it's huge man where did you
guys go just just all these different
coffee shop things Wow but he's the
smartest businessman in comedy yeah
there's nobody smarter
Joe Rogan works smart and it's like Joe
Rogan a five-tool player when the grace
ever do it yeah but Tom cigars the
greatest businessman I've ever seen in
comedy nobody were like everything he
talks about he turns into a t-shirt that
sells out right he's smart I love it huh
a lot to learn man that's one cool thing
about this whole job in universe is that
it's there's a lot to learn you think
podcasts are just starting you think
this is you know we're not even close to
the golden era
we're like 10% of the u.s. populations
listens to podcasting dude when I used
to do the Noddy show which was like four
or five years ago we used to get [ __ ] it
was the funny show I've ever done
we get 5,000 viewers 5,000 listeners all
my friends were getting 50 60 70 were
getting five but there was so long dude
that was the dark ages of podcasting
yeah like we're not even in the golden
era and look how good it is and it's
about to get even bigger dude Wow
it's dude five years from now it's gonna
be knots do you ever think that like one
day podcasters could like walk on the
moon yeah dude
earth is hollow bro that's the big thing
nobody knows about watch Godzilla bro
they talk about that [ __ ] earth is
hollow here's something when you stepped
on it a lot when you hear like a
yeah I mean it's do you know that we've
only been like a couple miles into the
crust we don't know what yeah we don't
know what's in the mill disperse nah
dude up you know what I'm thinking
nougat lady's gonna say I'm Tripoli in a
pleasure thank you very much thanks
twink sorry thanks Gianni and thank you
Nick and I didn't mean to call you
[Music]
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]
[Music]